[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami de la montagne et de
partout bonsoir vous avez devant vous un
champion de saut à ski regardez bien
mais tu n'as pas de ski tu n'as que les
bâtons nounours et ne gesticule pas de
la sorte tu vas tomber ton but
laissez-moi rire patron le grand
champion n'ont même pas besoin de ski et
une tombe jamais il vole il plane je
glisse oh au secours pas trop au secours
nounours quelle catastrophe
allô allô je suis chez cornichon allô
bonsoir cornichon va vite dehors il est
arrivé à un accident à nounours il vient
de glisser de notre nuage j'y vais tout
de suite
je crois
accident où sont les pansements au fond
du panier d'Hélène rouge
[Musique]
alors mon ami on a un petit bobo oh oh
oui d'accord allô assieds-toi là
allez pansements ne bouge pas nours là
tu vas te guéri
tiens mon nounours c'est de la tisane
aux herbes calmante
les plantes c'est ce qu'il y a de
meilleur et avec celle-ci vous oublierez
tous vos soucis
ce sont des plantes doux de la grande
forêt
là et voilà retiens ta tête droite
c'est douloureux
[Musique]
t'endors pas
le petit marchand de sable t'attends
d'abord les bras
allô viens nous je t'accompagne à ton
échelle
aide-moi du pépite
les petits
faites de beaux rêves camarade
tiens il a oublié ses bâtons de ski le
pauvre cher
ours bonne nuit Dada bonne nuit mon
petit cornichon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi nounours oui pas trop ça va
mieux j'ai bu une infusion qui fait
dormir
tu es un gros maladroit et j'espère que
cet accident te servira de leçon
je mettrais des skis la prochaine fois
bonne nuit les enfants faites de beaux
rêves
[Musique]